♪ ♪
>> Emily: WELCOME BACK.
THE DEMOCRATS BEING ACCUSED OF
FOCUSING ON PARTISAN POLITICS
WHILE MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
SUFFER DURING THE PANDEMIC.
NANCY PELOSI RAMPING UP PERSONAL
ATTACKS ON PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE THESE COMMENTS COMING
OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE, THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN HELD
RESPONSIBLE.
AND WE HAVE INSISTED ON THE
TRUTH.
I’M EMBARRASSED SOMETIMES ABOUT
HOW THE PRESIDENT TALKS.
HE IS CRUDE AND THAT HE DOES NOT
WANT CHILDREN TO HEAR THAT, BUT
THIS IS DANGEROUS.
>> Emily: ADAM SCHIFF SENSING
THE NEED FOR NEW INVESTIGATIONS.
THE DEMOCRAT GOING AS FAR AS
COMPARING THE CORONAVIRUS
RESPONSE TO IMPEACHMENT.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE STRONGEST ECHO OF WHAT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT DURING THE
TRIAL WAS WHEN HE WAS EARLIER
TALKING ABOUT HOW HE DID NOT
WANT TO RETURN THE CALLS FROM
GOVERNORS.
HE DID NOT WANT HIS
VICE PRESIDENT TO RETURN THE
CALLS FROM GOVERNORS THAT WERE
NOT SAYING NICE THINGS ABOUT
HIM.
THAT WAS SUCH A PROFOUND AND
DISTURBING ECHO OF WHAT HE TRIED
TO DO WITH UKRAINE.
SO SADLY, AS WE HAVE POINTED OUT
DURING THE TRIAL, A MAN WITH NO
MORAL COMPASS WILL NEVER FIND
HIS WAY, AND THIS PRESIDENT
CERTAINLY HASN’T.
>> Emily: DANA, I WANT TO
START WITH YOU, WHILE SO MANY
ARE SUFFERING ECONOMICALLY, WHAT
IS YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
SPEAKER PELOSI’S ANTI-TRUMP
MESSAGING AND WHAT EFFECTS THAT
MIGHT HAVE ON THE ELECTION AS WE
APPROACH THE CAMPAIGN CLOSER.
>> Dana: WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
POLITICS.
SO WE ARE JUST GOING TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH IT AND EXCEPT AT THAT
THERE WILL BE BARS THROWN FROM
BOTH SIDES.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
ADAM SCHIFF WAS TRYING TO DO WAS
TO REMIND EVERYONE THAT HE WAS
THE ONE THAT LED THE CHARGE ON
IMPEACHMENT, BECAUSE NOBODY
TALKS ABOUT IMPEACHMENT OR
ADAM SCHIFF ANYMORE, SO THAT WAS
A WAY FOR HIM TO GET BACK IN THE
NEWS.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT FOR
EXAMPLE, CHUCK SCHUMER HAS SAID
THAT TODAY ARE GOING TO
INTRODUCE LEGISLATION TO REMOVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S NAME FROM
BEING PUT ON ANY OF THE FUTURE
STIMULUS CHECKS, BECAUSE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THE DEMOCRATS
FELL INTO WAS THAT THEY SAID
THAT THE PRESIDENT’S NAME BEING
ON A CHECK MADE THERAPY OF DELAY
IN GETTING A CHECK SETTLED, THAT
TURNED OUT NOT TO BE TRUE.
BUT NOW THAT CHUCK SCHUMER WANTS
TO PASS LEGISLATION THAT SAYS
THAT THE PRESIDENT CAN PUT HIS
NAME ON CHECKS, THAT’S ACTUALLY
GOING TO DELAY CHECKS GETTING
OUT.
SO I THINK ON THE MERITS, THEY
KEEP GETTING SORT OF NIPPED FROM
BEHIND BY THEIR OWN DEEDS.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS, I DO THINK
THAT CONGRESS HAS A ROLE, AND IT
SHOULD BE A BIPARTISAN ROLE FOR
OVERSIGHT AND HOW ALL OF THIS
MONEY IS GOING TO BE SPENT AND
DOLED OUT.
WE WOULD INSIST ON IT FOR ANY
ADMINISTRATION.
AND I THINK THAT EVERYBODY
SHOULD WANT TO KNOW AND HAVE
ACCOUNTABLE WHERE THIS MONEY IS
GOING TO BE SPENT.
BECAUSE WE DO WANT TO HELP
PEOPLE.
WE DO WANT TO HELP PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY NEED IT.
>> Emily: JESSE, WE PAY THE
SALARIES FOR THESE GUYS, WOULD
YOU SAY THAT IT IS DESERVING OF
OUR TAX DOLLARS THAT
CHUCK SCHUMER IS AS DANA POINTED
OUT TAKING MORE TIME FOR THESE
RELIEF CHECKS BECAUSE HE DOES
NOT WANT THE PRESIDENT’S NAME ON
THEM?
>> Jesse: IT IS STICKY TACK,
YOU KNOW, IT GETS A HEADLINE.
I DON’T THINK THAT IT WILL EVEN
HAPPEN.
IT REALLY WILL DELAY IT, AND
THEN YOU CAN PIN JOB LOSSES ON
CHUCK, BUT YOU CANNOT TRUST
DEMOCRATS WITH POWER.
THEY ALWAYS ABUSE IT AND THEN
COLLUDE WITH THE MEDIA AND
SPREAD LIES TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE STILL SAYING THAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID THE VIRUS WAS A
HOAX.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THE
PRESIDENT TOLD AMERICANS TO
DRINK LYSOL.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO DELAY THE
ELECTION.
AT THIS STUFF IS CRAZY.
IT’S LIKE HAVING CHILDREN AND
EVERY KID’S GOING ROOM TO ROOM
TO ROOM IN YOUR HOUSE MAKING A
MESS, AND YOU ARE JUST FOLLOWING
THEM ROOM TO ROOM AND HAVING TO
CLEAN UP AFTER THEM ALL THE
TIME.
AND YOU CAN’T GET ANY WORK DONE,
BECAUSE THEY NEVER LEARN, AND
THEY NEVER LISTEN.
AND THAT’S WHAT IT’S LIKE
DEALING WITH THE MEDIA.
>> Dana: IS THIS HAPPENING AT
YOUR HOUSE?
>> Jesse: PERHAPS IT IS.
AND PERHAPS THAT WAS ME JUST
GETTING SOMETHING OFF MY CHEST.
BUT IN REALITY, IT’S WHAT THEY
DO, AND THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE
GOING TO DO WITH THESE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEES.
YOU KNOW, YOU’RE GOING TO SEE
THEM SUBPOENA, LEAK, AND LIVE,
JUST LIKE THEY DID WITH RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
AND WE ARE GOING TO DIE IN HALF
TO FACT-CHECK IT, AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL WASTE A LOT
OF MANPOWER, MONEY, AND TIME
FIXING ALL THE MESS.
AND HOW BAD WILL IT BE COMPARED
TO THE LAST ALLEGATION THAT HE
WAS A TRAITOR.
IT CAN’T BE THAT BAD, THE BEST
THAT THEY WILL GET IS THAT MONEY
WENT TO THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION
SOMEHOW, SOMEWAY.
AND WHAT THEY WILL DO IS THEY
WILL FIND MONEY THAT WENT TO A
GUY THAT TEN YEARS AGO HAD A
CONTRACT TO MOW THE LAWN AT
BEDMINSTER, AND THEY ARE GOING
TO JAM UP SOME SPLASHY HEADLINE
THAT MAKES IT LOOK LIKE TRUMP
GOT MONEY.
WE WILL HAVE TO CORRECTED AND
THEN THEY WILL MOVE ONTO THE
NEXT ROOM AND MAKE A MESS THERE.
>> Emily: ALL RIGHT, SO JUAN,
FROM THE BIRD’S-EYE VIEW
PERSPECTIVE, AND 20 MILLION
AMERICANS ARE NOW UNEMPLOYED,
HOW IS THIS THE ACTION WE NEED
OR EFFECTIVE LEADERSHIP IF
PEOPLE LIKE ADAM SCHIFF ARE
GOING AROUND SAYING THEY ARE
GOING TO LAUNCH AN INVESTIGATION
INTO THE CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE?
>> Juan: THERE WILL INEVITABLY
BE SOME 9/11 COMMISSION, BUT TO
ME, WHEN YOU HAVE THE
LOS ANGELES LAKERS GETTING MONEY
THAT IS INTENDED FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES, THEY ARE A
$1 BILLION ENTERPRISE, ONE OF
THE MOST VALUABLE IN AMERICA,
THEY HAVE MONEY AND THEY HAD TO
RETURN IT.
OR YOU HEAR ABOUT RUTH CHRIS, OR
SHAKE SHACK, ANY OF THE BIG
COMPANIES ABOUT ANYBODY WHO IS
TIED IN TO MORGAN STANLEY AND
ALL THE BIG BANKS GETTING
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT OR TODAY
HEARING ABOUT PEOPLE JUST
LOOKING FOR MORE HELP, AND THE
COMPUTER SYSTEM BREAKS DOWN,
GOSH, IF THIS WAS THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THERE WILL BE
LOTS OF SCREAMING AND CALLS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY, AND HE WOULD
SAY, THAT’S RIGHT, WE NEED
ACCOUNTABILITY IN GOVERNMENT
THAT REALLY SERVES THE PEOPLE.
SO IT IS NOT AN ISSUE.
TO ME IT IS ABOUT AT THIS POINT
WHAT YOU ARE GETTING IS THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAVING
BOTCHED AND SLOW TO SOME OF THE
RESPONSE LOOKING FOR SCAPEGOATS.
AND SO LET’S GO BACK TO
ADAM SCHIFF, WE DON’T LIKE HIM.
WE FEEL LIKE WE DEFEATED
ADAM SCHIFF.
ADAM SCHIFF WANTS ATTENTION.
THE FACT IS THEY ARE TRYING TO
POINT THE FINGER AND DISTRACT
PEOPLE FROM THEIR OWN FEELINGS.
>> Emily: GREG, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> Greg: WELL, I FEEL LIKE
JESSE HAVING TO GO BACK AND
CLEAN UP A ROOM AFTER JUAN SPEWS
THAT NONSENSE ABOUT EVERYTHING
HAPPENING SO LATE.
LET’S REMIND EVERYBODY THAT HE
CLOSE DOWN TRAVEL AND IT WAS THE
DEMOCRATS THAT CALLED HIM A
RACIST FOR THAT, ALSO, I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE AN INVESTIGATION AND
HOW THIS VIRUS CAME ABOUT, THE
MEDIA CANNOT EVEN BOTHER TO ASK
THAT.
INSTEAD, THEY WERE DEFENDING
CHINA AND DEFENDING THEM BY
ACCEPTING THE FACT THAT THEY
WERE GIVING, AND WERE TOTALLY
OKAY WITH THE FACT THAT THEY
WERE COVERING IT UP.
THIS IS A VIRUS THAT CAME FROM A
COMBINATION OF BATS AND OTHER
PROTEIN.
WE DON’T KNOW WHERE IT IS FROM.
IF IT IS FROM A LAB, IF IT WAS
BIOWARFARE.
I’VE NO IDEA.
I’M ASSUMING IT WAS A MISTAKE.
IS IT NATURAL OR ARTIFICIAL?
THESE ARE QUESTIONS THAT DON’T
INTEREST THE MEDIA.
NUMBER THREE-POINT.
NOBODY IS GOING AFTER
ADAM SCHIFF.
ADAM SCHIFF IS INSERTING HIMSELF
INTO THE STORY.
REMEMBER, HE LAUNCHED THIS
HORRIBLE IMPEACHMENT NIGHTMARE
ADVENTURE THAT TIED UP THE
GOVERNMENT IN THE MEDIA, AND WE
ASKED OURSELVES ON "THE FIVE,"
WHAT DAMN STORY WAS BEING MISSED
WHEN THIS WAS HAPPENING?
I WAS THE CORONAVIRUS.
NOBODY SHOWED UP BECAUSE THEY
WERE GETTING THEIR QUESTIONS
READY FOR THE DAMN HEARING ON
IMPEACHMENT.
SO WE ARE GOING TO ALLOW THE
RINGLEADER THAT PUT OUR COUNTRY
AND JEOPARDY AND ALMOST RUINED
OUR ECONOMY BECAUSE HE WAS
CHASING HIS WHALE OF AN
IMPEACHMENT, YOU’VE GOT TO BE OF
YOUR MIND!
HE IS LIKE A DUDE WHO GETS
ARRESTED FOR A DUI AND THEN
THREE HOURS LATER HE IS BACK IN
THE CAR DRIVING DRUNK.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE THE KEYS AWAY
FROM ADAM SCHIFF.